Now, let's look at the counter measures.
The first is prevention.
For example,
we can limit the content of a computer
to the untrusted outside world.
Meaning that it would not accept
documents or programs, or
any active contents
from other computers.
And of course, this will impose major
inconvenience to a computer user.
The second approach is detection.
This means that we use
a monitor to watch out for
telltale signs of malware infection.
The third approach is removal,
meaning that once we detect
that there's malware infection,
we will remove the malware and
perhaps we should also patch the system.
Given that prevention severely
hampers productivity,
detections really the main counter
measure that we can use, and
there are four generations of antivirus
software, or malware detection software.
The first is malware scanners.
These scanners use signatures or
patterns of known viruses to scan
program files to find matches.
And if there's a match,
that means that this program file
has been infected by a known virus.
One of the examples of
signatures of viruses.
A signature of a virus is typically
the unique sequence of instructions of
the virus code or the unique infection
marker that the virus would use.
These simple scanners are not
effective against polymorphic viruses.
And the reason is that for
polymorphic virus each instance is
encrypted with randomly generated key,
such that there's no unique signature
across all instances of the same virus.
The second is the heuristic scanners,
they are based on possible
effects of infection.
For example, if a program file has
been infected with a virus code
the checksum of the original
file will have changed
because new contents has
been added to the file.
However, this approach can be
defeated if the malware deliberately
makes sure that the checksum
after infection remains the same.
For example,
the malware can include some additional
bytes at the end of the file to make
sure that the checksum remains the same
as the file before its infection.
The third is activity traps.
These detectors look for
particular kind of activities that
malware will typically
perform on a system.
Such as modifying the Windows registry
file, or reading the password file and
sending it to the Internet, and so on.
These detectors are based on our
knowledge of malware activities,
therefore, these detectors
are not effective
against malware that performs new
kinds of malicious activities.
The fourth is the so called,
full feature analysis,
which is the state of the art.
It typically involves
multiple approaches.
For example, it typically
includes host-based monitoring.
That in turn includes activity traps and
scanners.
It also includes network-based monitors
that analyze traffic to the Internet.
For example, if there's a traffic that
contains password file to Internet
server, that can be a telltale sign
that a malware has infected and
host, and is attempting to
steal the password file.
Similarly, if there's a connection to a
website that is well-known for a malware
download, there's also a telltale sign
that the end host has been infected.
And the malware on that host is
attempting to download an update.
And you can also include
a sandboxing-based analysis approach.
A sandbox is typically used to
run a piece of executable, for
example, an attachment from an e-mail,
to see whether this executable would
exhibit any malicious activities.
By executing this executable
in a sandbox, we can make
sure that there's no permanent
damage to our system and network.
And we can observe the behaviors of
the executable from outside a sandbox.
So that we can be certain whether
this executable is a malware or not.